الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قالت هيئه
الاركان العامه للقوات الاوكرانيه انها
قتلت اكثر من الف عسكري روسي خلال عمليات
قصف ومعارك بين قوتها والقوات الروسيه
التي شنت يوم امس بل شنت يوم امس نحو 40
غاره في عموم اوكرانيا وقدرت الهيئه
الخسائر الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب بنحو 170
الف قتيل وقال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه اولكسان ان قوته ستبدا قريبا
هجوما مضافا بعد ان صمدت في وجه الحمله
العسكريه التي شنتها روسيا في الشتاء
وافادت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بان
قواتها تستمر في صد الهجمات الروسيه في
باخموت وفي مناطق اخرى كما ان مدفعيتها
ومنظوماتها الصاروخيه اصابت نقطتي تحكم
للقوات الروسيه ومجمعين للصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات ومستودع ذخيره